determinar si las parejas ordenadas 35 y
17 son soluciones a la desigualdad 5 x 3
mayor o igual que 25 aunque el mayor o
igual que 25 así que lo que vamos a
intentar hacer es que a partir de esta
de estos pares de este par de puntos
vamos a ver qué pasa cuando lo
sustituimos en esta desigualdad y ver si
la satisface o no entonces primero vamos
a intentar con el 35
así que ponemos vamos a poner vamos a
sustituir y ponemos 5 por equis que en
este caso es 3 en este caso es 3 déjenme
hacerlo en otro color aunque hay 5 x 3
cinco por tres menos tres por y ahora
sustituimos la aie que en este caso es 5
así que tenemos 3 por 5 y vamos a ver si
esto es mayor o igual que 25 ok no
sabemos así que 5 por 3 es 15 menos 3
por 5 son 15 también y esto vamos a ver
si es mayor o igual que 25 y le ponemos
signo de interrogación porque no sabemos
si esto es cierto pero bueno 15 menos 15
0 y esto será mayor o igual que 25
y esto no es cierto verdad esto
realmente en realidad 0 es menor que 25
así que esto no es cierto así que esta
pareja ordenada no es solución a la
desigualdad no es solución
resolución ok simplemente sustituimos en
la ecuación o en la desigualdad y vemos
que no se cumple la desigualdad ahora
vamos a intentar con el otro punto con
el 1 menos 7 entonces 5 por x que en
este caso es uno menos 3
y que es -7 ok y esto será mayor o igual
que 25 otra vez no sabemos vamos a ver
cinco por uno es cinco y menos tres por
menos siete son más 21 es decir menos
menos 21 vamos a hacerlo por pasos y
queremos ver si es mayor o igual que 25
ahora 5 21 que es menos por menos da más
y esto será mayor o igual que 25 bueno 5
más 21 son 26 y que en efecto es mayor o
igual que 25 porque así que esto
funciona funciona para este punto y este
punto de solución ya ya hemos visto un
poquito de cómo visualizar esto vamos a
graficar la desigualdad no vamos a no no
quiero mostrarles exactamente cómo voy a
hacer esto de una forma muy rigurosa
solo quiero que lo visualicen muy bien
entonces vamos a ponerlo esto en déjenme
usar otro color
5 dije otro color creo que el día de hoy
no tengo problemas cambiando colores y
tenemos 5 x menos tres y mayor o igual
que 25 y lo que quiero hacer
es cambiar esto en la forma pendiente
ordenada al origen muy bien entonces
resto 5x de ambos lados y tengo menos 3
ye mayor o igual que menos 5 x más 25 ok
eso fue restando 5x de ambos lados ok y
ahora vamos a dividir ambos lados de la
desigualdad o si de la desigualdad por
menos 3 ok entonces cuando dividimos o
multiplicamos una desigualdad por un
número negativo el símbolo el signo de
la desigualdad cambia de sentido verdad
entonces tendremos menor o igual que
menos 5 entre menos 3 simplemente es 5
tercios por equis y luego 25 por medio
entre menos 3 es menos 25 tercios muy
bien entonces sí vamos a graficar esto
esta es la expresión de una desigualdad
que es menor o igual que 5 tercios por x
menos veinticinco tercios aunque
entonces sí vamos a graficar esto
ok vamos a hacerlo a groso modo en una
pequeña gráfica solo para visualizar un
poco de qué estamos hablando así que la
intersección con el eje y es menos 25
tercios que es un poquito más que 8
aquí está el 8 y un poquito más aquí
está la intersección ok con menos 25
tercios y tiene una pendiente de 5
tercios eso quiere decir que por cada
tres que avanzó en la dirección x
aumenta 5 en la dirección y en la
dirección vertical así que esta línea se
vería algo así ok
más o menos a grosso modo la línea se
vería de esta forma ok
qué pasaría si sigues igual a 5 tercios
de x menos 25 tercios ok pero aquí
tenemos una desigualdad menor o igual
porque entonces para cualquier x la ye
que satisface son todos estos valores
por ejemplo fijándonos en una equis ok
fijándonos en este x particular todas
las 10 que satisfacen la solución son
toda esta área de aquí abajo ok es las
10 menores o iguales que esta línea y
por supuesto incluimos la línea porque
tenemos la posibilidad de que sea igual
verdad porque si no esté pondríamos la
línea punteada
ahora vamos a ver si estos puntos están
por ejemplo empezamos con el 35 ok
entonces subimos ahora aquí 5 y aquí
está el 35 que como podemos ver está
fuera de la región que hemos sombreado
ahora el 1 menos 7 está casi dentro de
la línea verdad pero está en esta región
ok
así que si está justo en esta en este
lugar está en el conjunto en el área que
es el conjunto de la solución verdad
espero que esto te haya dado mucho
sentido de cómo visualizar estas
desigualdades